[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 el tema de hoy es
una medida que si se hace realidad será
una prueba sin precedentes para evaluar
las penas carcelarias de las mujeres con
la lupa del enfoque de género el
gobierno de Colombia sancionó una ley
pionera en la región o el que busca
excarcelar a las mujeres que pagan penas
de prisión durante cinco días a la
semana es un beneficio que aplica para
las madres cabeza de hogar para que
puedan estar presentes en los procesos
educativos de sus hijos y cortar el
círculo de violencia en los hogares
además de hacer frente a la crisis
carcelaria que vive el país Aún se
espera que esta ley sea regulada pero
ese desde ya un avance del enfoque de
género Andrés triviño nos cuenta de qué
se trata esta ley de alternativa penal
5000 madres serán liberadas de las
cárceles en Colombia así las mujeres que
hayan cometido delitos menores y que sus
penas no superen los 8 años podrán salir
de prisión durante cinco días a la
semana para cuidar a sus hijos por eso
este proyecto de ley para cinco mil
mujeres
es tan importante porque inicia otra
manera de entender las cosas que la
presa se junte con sus hijos liberada
que el amor se pueda producir y no sea
interrumpido por las cadenas
que quitar esas cadenas entre el amor es
lo que nos permite ser una mejor
sociedad
la ley fue aprobada sin muchos reparos
en el 2021 por el congreso pero fue
objetada por el entonces presidente Iván
Duque este año finalmente fue sancionada
por el mandatario Gustavo Petro
convirtiéndose en una iniciativa con
enfoque de género sin antecedentes en la
región las beneficiadas deberán pagar
algún tipo de servicio social luego
demostrar que delinquieron por
condiciones de vulnerabilidad o
incapacidad económica para alimentar a
su familia la ley de alternatividad
penal Busca evitar mayor criminalidad en
el futuro además de otorgar a las madres
un subsidio mensual en un país que
enfrenta un hacinamiento carcelario del
48%, el cual ha tenido un incremento del
429% de mujeres presas pasando de 1500
recluidas en 1991 a 7.948 en 2018 esta
ley aplicará para las mujeres que hoy
están en prisión y también para aquellos
que enfrenten ahora un proceso penal así
con una política criminal que adopta el
enfoque de género se logrará reducir el
hacinamiento en cárceles de mujeres y
reducir la vulneración a derechos
humanos que se ven en ellas ahora el
gobierno tiene seis meses para expedir
un decreto que regule la forma en la que
las mujeres prestarán el servicio social
a la comunidad que incluya a entidades
públicas y privadas y desarrolle un plan
pedagógico para la rama judicial la
conversación sobre este tema es con
Claudia Cardona ella es directora de
mujeres libres Colombia y además es
activista por los derechos de las
mujeres privadas de la libertad y sus
familiares ella misma estuvo Privada de
la libertad Así que entiende de primera
mano todos los problemas de una mujer
que ejerce las labores de cuidado cuando
está Privada de su libertad Muchas
gracias a usted Claudia por estar en
ellas hoy
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes por
invitarme en este espacio pues empiezo
por preguntarle lo que parecería obvio a
usted le parece que tiene futuro esta
medida porque hay Quienes se la ven con
desconfianza porque la delincuencia
siempre la estamos asociando con cárcel
y no con vulnerabilidad esto es otra
manera de ver las cosas
Claro que sí pues mujeres libres a la
organización que dirijo acá en Colombia
desde hace cinco años participó en todo
el transcurso del proyecto de ley sobre
esta alternatividad penal para mujeres
simplemente pues Buscar que se reduzcan
las los efectos de la prisionalización
no solo en las mujeres sino los niños
niñas adolescentes y las personas que
estaban bajo cuidado de estas mujeres
que llegan a la cárcel bueno Cuál es la
situación hoy en Colombia de las
familias de las mujeres que están en
prisión
pues es una situación bien impactante yo
pongo como ejemplo siempre que el hijo
mayor se hace cargo de los hijos menores
pero tampoco puede conseguir trabajo es
difícil también sostener a la familia
hay muchos niños niñas que quedan solos
y se dedicaban a la prostitución a las
drogas no consiguen trabajo entonces
también
es una situación muy difícil para estos
menores bueno y hay una situación
particular Claudia que a mí siempre me
ha llamado la atención y es la que
tienen que enfrentar las madres de hijos
pequeños o las mujeres que llegan en
estado de embarazo a los centros penales
porque hasta cierto punto se les permite
convivir con ellos pero después lo que
ahí es una separación desgarradora en la
que estos pequeños terminan Al cuidado
de tutores y su madre Pues está
imposibilitada para ejercer esa
maternidad Cómo cambiaría Esto bueno con
con esta nueva ley
lo que ocurre Sí cuando están en las
cárceles los chicos deben salir a los
tres años y no hay ninguna
acceso a psicólogo o para lo que usted
dice ese desprendimiento entre madre e
hijo
Y entonces se vuelve muy problemático no
entonces esa ruptura de los lazos
familiares es no solamente se da entre
las mujeres que tienen hijos en la
cárcel sino al al momento de ser
llevadas a la cárcel y dejan sus
familias afuera
Claro pero esto tiene unas consecuencias
porque estamos perpetuando unos ciclos
de violencia que hasta hoy no tenían
solución y que además no tenían
precedente en América Latina Colombia
podría dar un paso adelante que sería un
experimento social gigante para ver que
efectivamente necesitamos validar las
tareas de cuidado ya sea por imposición
o por convicción pues somos las mujeres
las que ejercemos estas labores de
cuidado y desde la cárcel pues es
imposible
claro muchas mujeres incluso desde la
cárcel comienzan a ejercer estas labores
de Cuidado pero es mucho más difícil
estar pendiente de las familias además
Hay momentos de desespero de no poder
poder hacer algo más sobre las familias
sí los chicos presentan situaciones
afuera de dependencia de drogas lo que
ya he dicho y las mujeres adentro se les
dificulta ejercer estas labores de
cuidado pues que sí que por la sociedad
han sido impuestas Pues a la mujer pero
que se ven reflejadas en la
encarcelación de las mujeres y sobre
todo que Claudia Aquí quisiera que usted
nos recordara a todos Cuáles son esas
condiciones que deben reunir las mujeres
que serían susceptibles de ser
excarceladas o que incluso están Ya en
un proceso penal y podrían librarse de
ir a la cárcel porque esto no se trata
de premiar El crimen sino se trata de
ver los delitos con la gravedad que
acarrea no hay unas condiciones
específicas para que una mujer pueda
acceder a este beneficio
Sí claro no son como normalmente lo
están diciendo que muchas mujeres van a
salir si no son unos delitos específicos
como delitos menores por hurto delitos
relacionados con drogas y otros delitos
no violentos con penas inferiores a ocho
años se excluye por ejemplo el delito de
violencia intrafamiliar Sí pero también
pues las mujeres deben demostrar que en
el momento de la comisión del delito
estaba en vulnerabilidad tenía cargo a
alguna familiar por ejemplo los niños
niñas adolescentes o alguna persona con
discapacidad a una enfermedad grave esto
debe ser demostrado
qué qué podemos decir Claudia del
reconocimiento del peso que tienen las
labores de Cuidado con esta ley que hay
que decirlo no ha sido aplicada tiene
que pasar aún por una reglamentación
porque mire tanta es la carga en general
que asumimos las mujeres que y tampoco
el apoyo que recibimos de nuestros
compañeros familias o Estados si usted
quiere que el delito pasa a ser una de
las opciones no una de las cosas que a
veces hay que hacer para poder alimentar
a una familia y de ahí esto que usted
nos explicaba de argumentar Esa
condición de vulnerabilidad
hablemos un poco de eso
Pues mira con esta ley Colombia comienza
a tener un enfoque de género en la
política criminal Y esto es algo que no
nunca ha pasado entonces Y esto qué
quiere decir que se tiene en cuenta las
circunstancias de la comisión del delito
que son diferentes a las a las
circunstancias que de un hombre cometer
un delito y sobre todo por ejemplo con
informes que sacó la el comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja y la
universidad javeriana muchas mujeres han
cometido estos delitos por situaciones
económicas Sí para el sostenimiento de
las familias Entonces es bastante
importante la ley porque precisamente
resalta estas labores de cuidado de
protección y de pues de estar aportando
económicamente a las familias y que
recae en las mujeres bueno Y esto nos
muestra que cuando hay enfoque de género
en la política pública podríamos
evitarnos muchísimos dolores de cabeza
incluyendo Pues el de la política
penitenciaria Claudia Quiero preguntarle
por los desafíos de La regulación de
esta nueva ley tiene el Estado o el
gobierno seis meses para hacer una
regulación y pues Del dicho al hecho hay
un camino largo y esperamos Que se
cumpla pero Pero qué es lo que hace
falta
Pues
en este momento sé que el Ministerio de
Justicia está adelantando la
reglamentación y tiene muchos desafíos
incluso la ley tiene un artículo que
habla de una política de empleabilidad y
es un desafío muy grande porque al salir
de prisión no es nada fácil hay muchas
obstáculos no hay oportunidades para
nadie para hombres o mujeres Entonces
salir de la cárcel con un letrero que
dice ex privado de la libertad significa
no conseguir trabajo no tener acceso a
salud no tener ni siquiera poder abrir
una cuenta bancaria y pues mucho menos
pedir un préstamo pero Y estos son los
desafíos que deben enfrentar ahora al
gobierno para poder que estas mujeres
salgan de la cárcel y no solo
previamente preste el servicio a la
comunidad sino pueda tener oportunidades
y poder sostener a las familias Bueno
aquí se trata mucho más incluso que de
la propia mujer que Privada de la
libertad de todas sus redes de cuidado y
de cómo esto impacta directamente en las
comunidades no niños que van a tener una
perspectiva para crecer de una manera
diferente adultos mayores también que
van a tener la perspectiva de una vida
más digna si cuentan con el cuidado de
estas mujeres Porque esa es la realidad
y por eso ya para ir cerrando Claudia si
usted me permite le Quisiera hacer una
pregunta más personal porque es que el
cuidado las mujeres lo llevamos muy
hondo y vernos imposibilitadas de
ejercerlo genera unos dolores y unas
angustias que seguramente muchas
personas no van a comprender no menos
cuando están en una condición de
privilegio Entonces eso explicaría no
solamente muchos casos de delincuencia
sino la agonía de estas mujeres que
cometieron delitos menores por estar
presas usted cómo lo describiría
es terrible y muchas pues mujeres en
mujeres libres es una corporación que se
integra por mujeres que estuvimos
privadas de la libertad y lo hemos
hablado entre nosotras todo eso que vive
uno dentro de la cárcel y no poder hacer
nada
el cuidado de los hijos de las hijas es
bastante preocupante incluso todo eso
ese desespero lleva incluso a las
mujeres a suicidarse dentro de las
cárceles a cometer a querer quitarse la
vida porque es la situación tan difícil
tan complicada el no poder ayudar ver
que se presenta algo con los hijos
afuera que tuvieron por ejemplo un
accidente y y sentir esa sensación de de
no poder estar ahí de no poderlo cuidar
es bastante complicado y es duro y todo
esto no es
tratado dentro de prisión no hay una
atención
psicosocial por ejemplo para cada una de
las mujeres dependiendo también sus
necesidades específicas pues Mireya para
el cierre Claudia la gran conclusión
aquí es que las mujeres merecemos
derechos humanos sea cual sea nuestra
condición Yo le agradezco por aclararnos
un poco más sobre esta ley de
alternativa carcelaria que esperamos
llegue a buen término y pues estaremos
pendientes de Qué sucede Y de qué tanta
contención se les da a las mujeres para
que pueda llevarse a cabo efectivamente
Y que tenga éxito Le agradezco mucho a
usted pues muchísimas gracias por la
invitación y también tener la
oportunidad porque un reto también
importante de del gobierno es conseguir
las plazas para que estas mujeres puedan
prestarle servicio de utilidad pública
estas ongs en donde puedan abrirse estos
trabajos Pues ahí está el mensaje para
nuestros televidentes les recordamos que
pueden seguirnos viendo en nuestro sitio
web Franz 24 punto com y nos vemos
Próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]